but we're done except this challenge you
just practice what you preach you should
just start doing your own podcasts on
your own YouTube channel and you won't
you're waiting for the big payday from
Netflix which is never going to come
that's not even doing that anymore what
I'm doing is exactly what we talked
about I told you this is that it's a
problem is that you you go in and you've
got eleven thousand subscribers which is
what I have on my on my channel inside
true crime which every bribe should
subscribe so where's the camera are they
all on they're all on that you should
talk to this one though so inside true
crime it's my youtube channel you need
to subscribe so like right now I've got
eleven thousand subscribers right so the
issue is this let's say I do a podcast a
thirty forty five minute podcast I break
up all my stories into three or four
section three or four sections yeah
parts whatever and I do little thirty
minutes and explain the story and I get
a co-host and we talk we do the whole
thing and I explain I pull out the
documents and I go through it you know
it's kind of interesting great people
like it they get the whole store and
they see how it all unravel perfect the
problem is you do that well I have no
subscribers so I get barely any views
11,000 subscribers below all my content
and I don't really get any hits and so
you're basically doing it for free you
know that yeah let's say what your video
gets 50,000 hits in in a month it's a
few hundred dollars it's a lot of people
like oh you're gonna make like five
grand or are you out of your [ __ ]
mind you're gonna make no money like
it's not even worth doing it to make a
couple hundred dollars what you have to
do is you have to get a bulk of
subscribers you need to three hundred
thousand subscribe if you had 150 you
have a shot at a 150 to 200 thousand
subscribers right so how do you get 150
to 200 thousand subscribers you put out
content do I blow all of my decent
content then what do I do then I'm doing
these videos where these guys are going
hey look here's what a commissary list
looks like let me tell you about
commissary every one of these prisons
shows does it owe ten ways to get thrown
in the Shu here's what here's what the
shoes like here's how you can get
stabbed and pretty I mean [ __ ] are you
serious I can't do that but I'm not
gonna do those are ridiculous you know
here's a we're gonna go over um good
hygiene in prison are you serious who's
watching this so what happens is they
blow all their content and then they
start doing these were
Nicholas shows and then they get the
point where they start interviewing
other criminals well granted I've got a
bunch of content but I don't want to
blow that content upfront what I want to
do is get about if he's putting the
carriage before the horse mmm no I'm not
because here's what I want to do I want
to do the reviews I want to review
movies so I'll review movies I'll review
do 30 episodes put out every five days I
can do one time I'll do want to for 20
or 30 minutes on on catch me if you can
I love that movie I got other movies
that I've seen that it like um what's
that movie it's called I think it's
called conman it's horrible did you ever
see Conair no come on air that would Nic
Cage no it's about on air is the only
movie with Colin that I know
yeah there's a movie called comment I
believe it was horrible first of all I'd
love to see that do that it's nothing
like that Steve Buscemi in Conair yeah
last time I wash it was a [ __ ] come on
yeah come on Connie ur is not like that
I've been on Con Air it's not Danny
Trejo is a great actor Nick [ __ ] cage
it's not that's not what's happened is
that real it's not there's no that's a
movie of course it's not real no that
could be true I could actually see it
happen it's based on a movie well war
dogs was a movies they stole your memoir
yes they did you know you could do you
could watch all those con movies and
then you break down the con and talk
about where they went wrong and what
they could have done back that's the
shadiest idea oh my god
Matt you should take this place so I
mean did you guys get together and
decide to try
oh [ __ ] this is great I'm already happy
[Laughter]